the spread of the coronavirus the World
Health Organization says the risk of the
virus expanding worldwide is now
classified as very high and there are
new cases of the disease here in the
United States
16 cases so far have been detected and
confirmed in the US another 47 people
were evacuated from the diamond Princess
cruise ship and from the region in China
where the corona virus originated for a
total of 63 patients they are being
treated in eight different states but
overnight more suspected cases are
popping up some of them leaving doctors
with more questions Michael George is
here with the latest Michael good
morning good morning there are new
suspected cases in California Oregon and
Washington doctors treating the two
patients in California and Oregon don't
know how either of them may have
contracted the disease none of the
patients that travel to an area where
corona virus is circulated nor have they
come into close contact with a confirmed
case as health officials try to contain
the virus it continues to put millions
of people in this country on edge and
rattle the markets I understand that
this news is concerning however I want
to reassure you that our state and local
authorities are responding quickly to
the case Oregon governor Kate brown
announced Friday someone in her state
tested positive for corona virus while
the Centers for Disease Control haven't
confirmed the diagnosis the patient is
in isolation at a hospital this is a
case of community spread of the disease
much like the case from California
earlier this week the CDC says it's
aware of another suspected case of
community spread in Santa Clara County
California health officials say the
patient is an older woman with no known
contact with the disease what we know
now is that the virus is here present at
some level but we still don't know to
what degree well the CDC is trying to
track down anyone who's come into
contact with these patients the
government health agency admitted Friday
there's a shortage of test kits so far
fewer than 500 people in the US have
been tested meanwhile stores have been
selling out of face masks and the FDA
warned there could be potential
disruptions to supply or shortages of
critical medical products with as many
as 20 medications with ingredients from
China already at risk
the coronavirus sent another shiver down
the spines of investors Friday the Dow
Jones Industrial Average was clobbered
for a seventh straight day the key stock
index lost 3500 points this week wiping
out more than three trillion dollars
worth of value this has happened fast
and furious and there's way more
unknowns than there are no the travel
industry could suffer as well
losing potentially more than 46 billion
dollars a month as United Airlines
announced its suspending service to
major hubs in Asia Americans are
canceling more trips while travel
insurance demand jumped 60% we're
telling people they should make sure
their health insurance is in place
before they go that they should see
their health and a number of colleges
and universities are suspending their
study abroad programs and recalling
students to the US and Amazon is told
it's 800,000 employees to postpone any
non-essential travel both
internationally and within the US Jeff
all right Michael thank you very much
while US health officials work to
contain the spread of the virus here
eight more countries announced their
first cases on Friday to date more than
83,000 cases have been reported
worldwide the vast majority in China
cases have been confirmed in 53 nations
the virus is blamed for more than 2,800
deaths so far since it was first
reported late last year this morning the
State Department is urging Americans to
reconsider travel to Italy where there
are more cases than anywhere outside
Asia Charlie d'Agata is in Rome charlie
good morning good morning Jeff know
we're in Europe has been hit as hard as
Italy another 200 or so cases have been
announced and now there are new fears
that this virus may have been around for
weeks before it was picked up
there is growing evidence that Italy has
not only been one of the epicenters of
the global outbreak
it helped export it's spread around the
world we don't know what the values are
surviving
maybe that arrived at the earlier then
then we detected
he said the virus went viral with
carriers traveling from here undetected
to originating from China the virus has
now spread to more than 60 countries and
Counting New Zealand Nigeria Lithuania
Belarus Azerbaijan are the latest
countries to report new cases but South
Korea has seen the largest surge more
than 800 new cases in a single day have
swollen figures to more than 3,100 the
largest outbreak outside of China health
ministers are urging residents to stay
indoors and by all means avoid all
public events including church
gatherings Japan has taken even more
draconian measures cancelling classes
for more than 12 million students
shutting down schools for a month in
order to stem the spread of the virus
Iran another country that has given rise
to a cluster of infections took the
extraordinary step of cancelling Friday
prayers for the first time since the
Revolution in 1979
now the tourism industry here in Italy
had already taken a huge hit before that
State Department advisory the foreign
minister here is urging all visitors not
to cancel their plans Michelle all right
charlie thank you